superlatives time week 12 chris you get
the honors
oh well it was a four finger night baby
we have it's been a whole hour and we
haven't talked about
one of the two mvp candidates in the nfl
football oh
aaron rodgers it was a four finger night
because it was a four touchdown pass
night which leads to
a four finger pour of scotch after
uh and that's where it was very very
impressive but green bay
i mean come out just coming out the way
they did handling business last night
oh mitchell trubisky the bears is
they're gonna they're gonna be able to
add anything
yeah well okay hey i don't know you know
the the
the defense of the chicago bears didn't
show up last night and i know there was
noah keem hicks but
rogers was on his game early and then we
saw aaron jones
who looked like as healthy as he's
looked since he had that little calf
injury four five six weeks ago
to where when you saw those two things
start hitting on all cylinders you just
went oh crap here we go bear's got no
chance aaron jones is running a little
bit
roger seems on his game and this one was
over
as you know in the second quarter but
rogers was uh
pretty special last night and green
bay's offense looked damn good what are
you giggling about
not nothing nothing at all he's been
moving up the list of
mvp candidates and took another step
last night right now it's
mahomes russell wilson aaron rodgers and
ben roethlisberger saying what the hell
where am i why am i not in that
conversation here's matt lafleur the
coach of the packers
from last night talking about the
performance four touchdowns
four-finger pour for oh aaron rodgers
are you light years ahead of where you
were a year ago at this time offensively
yeah i i mean it certainly feels that
way
however we know that you're only as good
as your last performance
and so we've got to continue to get
better and find ways to get better
otherwise
you guys are going to say we stink so
it's week to week in this league
and and we've got to continue to dig
and and make sure that we're doing
everything in our power to get better
and better and better
yeah i mean look that's the challenge
and you're not gonna win every single
week unless you're the steelers you're
going to encounter challenges and how
you deal with adversity is critical
because
when you fall off the horse you got to
get back on the horse because if you
don't pretty soon the horse is going to
be trampling you and and that's
what we've seen happen to multiple teams
this year the packers to their credit
they do respond to adversity yeah
with with a better performance right we
we were talking last week with aaron
rodgers was he
upset enough that things didn't go their
way forget about it you move on you move
on to the next
game and uh and you you you make quick
work of the bears my god the bears
from five and one to five and six
five straight losses and uh this is not
where you wanna be
heading into december where you just
can't find a way
to win you can't find a way to generate
offense you can't find a way to keep it
close
and uh we've seen three head coaches
and four general managers go so far this
year right
uh he i i think that ryan pace and matt
nagy
are are on alert in uh in chicago
uh at some point before the end of the
season i feel like these teams are
making their decisions
before the season ends so they can get a
jump on the process of
of uh finding whoever their next one is
going to be
all right first superlative for me let
me start with
uh let look we talked about him a little
bit but but this is the john henry award
are you aware of john henry
like the really strong like strongest
man
john henry was the guy who who
had a competition with a machine to to
like dig a tunnel
uh and and and it supposedly there's
like three different states where it
supposedly happened west virginia is one
of them so we will claim that john henry
at the big bend tunnel did his thing
here where
he he he beat the machine and died of
exhaustion although
you know it's all legend and fable and
myth but
derek henry is john henry derrick henry
is the guy who will just go
and go and go and go and the titans need
to ride derrick henry
hopefully not until he dies of
exhaustion but ride him and ride him and
ride him as long as they can
it is clear it is obvious the guy is
unstoppable keep
feeding him keep feeding him keep
feeding him and don't make any
excuses for it and yeah there's a chance
he's going to get hurt there's always a
chance that anyone who plays football is
going to get hurt
don't let that keep you from playing to
your strengths
you paid him for a reason take full
advantage of him
that's what opens up the offense for the
passing game you're not going to turn
ryan tannehill into patrick mahomes even
though
patrick will homes more over the next
four years than the chiefs are paying my
homes which i still can't get my brain
around
derek henry is your guy you know when
they started off strong chris there was
an argument to be made
henry for mvp tannehill for mvp and
henry was on pftpm
making the case for tannehill for mvp no
one's making the case for tannehill now
it's derrick henry and if the titans
want to get as far as they possibly
can if they want to get back to the afc
championship game and beyond it's going
to be derrick henry
weekend and week out period that day
that's where it all starts
it is it's he's the driving force for
their offense and hey for their defense
who's not been great this year
but you know she's starting to show some
signs that it's getting better
you know he buys them time too with them
staying on the field and making plays
and putting them in a position of power
all the time with the lead and all that
he's amazing i've just i've never seen a
guy that big be able to change direction
as smoothly as he can
stop re-accelerate and the one thing
that jumped out to me about the game
yesterday you know didn't have huge
stats the first time around when the
colts beat the titans
but yesterday it's like the titans had
you know
another a curveball to go hey yeah okay
i know you're expecting us to run it up
the middle and derrick henry and
he's so impressive that way but look at
this these
you know next-gen stats about where he
got the ball
especially early in the game that was
the one thing i noticed mike
it was derek henry on the edge
oh you want to play eight people inside
the box that's fine
we'll cram you all down in there we're
gonna get him on the edge
and that's where he was very special
especially early on and then once they
got them spread out that way
man he started smashing him up the
middle with the run game there too
but uh really impressive win by the
titans
tannehill aj brown i mean the titans are
dangerous they can make plays and drive
down the field in a hurry with their
pass game or their run game
very explosive even though they're a run
first offense and run first team
i'm intrigued by the fact that he was
running so well to the outside because
in most games when they try to do that
that's when you see him unable to get
that head of steam that that he needs
and he gets knocked down before he can
really do anything and it's always up
the middle where he does most of the
damage he blasts through the first level
and uh and either runs over or runs past
the guys in the second and third levels
if you know if a defense is going to
give them the opportunity to hit the
edge
and if he can get to the edge then yeah
that's going to diversify the offense
and make them even more dangerous down
the stretch and the thing about the
titans
once we all climb on the bandwagon the
bandwagon collapses a little bit so
let's see if they can keep this going
they've got the browns
this week and the browns are desperate
to show that they can win a game that
they're not supposed to win they keep
winning the games they're supposed to
win they are 8-3
and uh this could be one of the best
games of the weekend if the browns can
show that they have a way to uh to slow
down the titans a little bit
and also beat the titans at their own
game run the ball we're on the ball i
mean this is 1972
next week when the titans and the browns
get together it is it's similar styles
it's gonna be a clash of wills there
i think tennessee's for real though i
think they figured it out mike to where
like
we're not gonna see any more of these
lulls during the season
we've seen the defense play better
lately and then with derek henry
the receiver's healthy now aj brown
corey davis
all of that i just think there's there's
too many weapons
on their offensive feel on their
offensive side of the ball
and then if they can get you know that
outside run game going
and things like that man they're going
to be hard to defend because
it it's not a complicated formula but it
is hard to fend with the way they
stretch the field in the past game in
that run game so
titan's hot i like in the way they're
looking certainly i'm a believer i know
that
uh all right superlative number two well
i mean i think i gotta i don't even know
what to call it i've been trying to but
the dirty south beat down
you do you see that dirty south beatdown
that what happened down in atlanta
i mean you're you're supposed to travel
down south
your your whole team isn't supposed to
just you know go down
south and crash and burn holy crap i
mean the raiders
talk about you know a tale of six days
and you know yeah the chiefs beat the
raiders twice
oh we were only a score away from
beating the chiefs we're great
we're pretty good we're almost one of
the best teams in football
oh no you're not sorry i mean they just
failed to show up
yesterday in that ra in that game
against the atlanta falcons
sloppy got whooped physically
couldn't convert fourth and ones fumbles
by josh jacobs
derek carr strip sack fumbles pick six i
mean that was a disappointing effort
i mean what's the nfl we know you can
lose on any sunday
but 43 to six to the falcons
that's that's like shocking and
embarrassing and i just can't believe we
saw that of the raiders football team
yeah i i can't either look i thought the
raiders would quickly reestablish
themselves because there was
a bright silver lining coming out of the
loss to the kansas city chiefs and maybe
they got blinded
by that silver lining maybe they thought
they were now at the position where
it's easy we can make it happen we we
don't need to scratch and claw and fight
and grind we can just show up and beat
this team
you know we joked last week about the
fact that john gruden was fired in tampa
for raheem morris a decade ago
you made a point yesterday that yeah you
know it's easy it's easy to see
it's easy to see this after the fact i
know but
raheem morris may know a thing or two
about john gruden's offense it's kind of
the reverse
of what gruden did to the raiders in the
super bowl the year after he went to the
buccaneers he knew everything there was
to know
about what the raiders were doing raheem
morris retained a lot
from his time working for john gruden
and
uh uh and and and you know yeah
maybe now we know why the buccaneers
fired gruden and elevated morris well
that's what's always scary about the
personal aspect
of the coaching matchups right where we
we already talked about like shanahan
and mcveigh and shanahan seems to have a
good feel for what mcveigh's offense
wants to do
and him and salah have game planned and
figured out how to slow that down
you know same thing here man i mean
you know that coaching staff we had down
in tampa on the defensive side of the
ball
with raheem morris and mike tomlin and
rod marinelli and monty kiffin
i mean it was every day a battle against
that defense
and that defense was breaking down
gruden's offense
and as we saw yesterday it was kind of
all over some of their
bread and butter type plays and i think
that's where
i thought atlanta could keep it close
and ultimately lose the game
but instead they dominated the football
game and uh this one was over
just about at halftime it's the second
time the falcons have caught a team
after
a a close loss that left them reeling
they got the vikings the week after that
game in seattle and now they get
the raiders after that game against the
chiefs and uh
you get a chance to knock them out and
raheem morris making the case
for uh an opportunity to be the coach of
the falcons beyond
2020 that that was his most impressive
win
yet yeah as the interim coach of the
team i mean you think if he just todd
gurley falls at the one yard line he's
sitting here at five and one and man
then there's real pressure on arthur
blank with her
there's pressure already that's going to
be interesting decision but wow i mean
that was a big
non-fall down by todd gurley that hurt
rahim moyes's
overall record and and the falcons
are much more alive in the playoff
chase and if they would somehow draw the
inside straight and get to the playoffs
then yeah
i think that they would uh they would uh
keep raheem morris next year all right
next one for me this is the leonlette
never got his shot at redemption award
because it was leon lett with the
all-time great gaffe
in super bowl history to go along with
his gaffe on thanksgiving
from that season of the season before
that
when he's when he's holding the ball low
going in for the touchdown and yeah they
still won the super bowl but it's still
something that we see every year when
the super bowl comes around and it was
dawn beebe
who knocked the ball away making
leonlette look like a fool and it was
dawn's son
chad who looked like a fool yesterday
when the vikings managed to stop the
panthers the game was a three-point edge
24-21 for carolina
bibi lets the punt bounce off of him
and it looked and felt like that was
that for the minnesota vikings well
thanks to some
horrible clock management by the
carolina panthers
they were held to a field goal it's
27-21
and chad bibi gets his shot at
redemption makes a big catch on the
drive the vikings just
i mean it was hot knife
through melted butter and when the
vikings got it back and i i heard you
say oh they're gonna have a chance to go
down and win the game next thing i know
they're on the carolina 10.
yeah and it's and it's chad bibi his
first
nfl touchdown catch see it was all
the setup for the dramatic conclusion
the fumble was just the setup to make it
even better but chad bibi
catches the pass that wins the game and
and even after that it wasn't
in the bag and it took a 53-yard missed
field goal by joey sly to secure the win
for the vikings but i felt
i felt good for chad bibi to get a
chance to redeem himself so quickly
because
uh that would have been a very long week
and maybe beyond
if chad bibi didn't get a chance to make
things right after fumbling that punt
yeah i mean definitely and just you know
minnesota and mike zimmer the way the
vikings keep
fighting kirk cousins yeah it was ugly
in the first half and things but
i mean hey he was clutch a lot of big
throws he's making and and i don't
always sit there and go oh
you know he's being given the gift of
like schematical
creativeness where guys are just wide
open all over the place
hey we know they want to run the ball
they're pretty simple
simple as far as how they throw the ball
they're aggressive down the field
i mean hey our man justin jefferson up
there he is phenomenal and they found
ways to get other guys the ball that's
where i really thought they would
struggle
throwing the football especially if
dalvin cook couldn't run
and dalvin cook didn't run all that well
but man they made plays in the passing
game and i gotta give kirk crescents a
lot of credit like that i mean he comes
up firing and he made some big throws in
the fourth quarter to help them win that
football game
i talked to peter king last night and
and sometimes in a conversation he would
just jump right in
to the question and the first thing he
said to me next five years
pick one of these two guys justin
jefferson or stefan diggs
setting aside the the financial
realities because that's gonna that's
gonna skew you toward jefferson setting
aside the contract
next five years jefferson or diggs who
would you want yeah i would go with
jefferson i would from what i've seen to
this point jefferson's special
and he's younger and he's bigger than
stefan diggs and i love stefan diggs i
mean i
there's no doubt i look at him as being
one of the 10 best receivers in football
right now
but justin jefferson is one of those
guys that could be also in the top 10
when we start next year
i mean there's no weakness to his game
that's the thing that i loved about him
with lsu
you know jump balls route running
running after the catch
breaking tackles all of those things oh
run blocking yeah we only play two
receivers you got to block for david
cook he does
everything he's a really awesome guy and
a really awesome football player
and uh yeah i think i would i would
favor him especially just because
more than not just because he's so young
right now and not even close to his
prime yet
um uh i you know you mentioned todd
gurley
falling down yeah uh and still landing
in the end zone and how that hurt the
falcons
that's a more obvious blunder than
justin jefferson last week he had that
crosser
against the fight against the cowboys as
the vikings were trying to drive down
and tie the game and he just
he was running with it before he caught
oh i know my god if he if he would have
secured that
that they could be riding what would it
be now a five-game winning streak
yeah yeah all right vikings uh vikings
not dead we know that
um i don't know where it even i have no
nickname i just want to go
don't forget about this guy all right
and that's like chub
all right i don't know what the hell to
say we don't talk about nick chubb
enough and how talented he is but just
like we talk about with derrick henry
and the titans
i mean chubb is i feel like sometimes
the unforgotten the the forgotten man
at running back maybe that's what i need
to call it the forgotten man
award because he is one of the best
running backs in football
and they just like the vikings of the
titans
everything is about chub and the run
game
and if that's successful man then we're
pretty successful everywhere else
but in a day yesterday where that
jaguars team moved the ball up and down
the field on the browns made it a
football game
you know chubb's ability to run make big
plays and baker mayfield
even though he had a few throws where i
went man how did he miss that he made
some awesome throws throughout the
football game too
and cleveland at least they will say
this they're not falling asleep at the
wheel even though they're not impressive
you know they keep winning football
games for the most part have won all the
games they should win
i don't know if i sit here and go oh i
think they're going to win a bunch of
games in the playoffs
but i think they're certainly a playoff
caliber team and it's looking like
they're going to get in here no doubt
you know i'm amazed it's 23 minutes
after the hour our second hour of the
program today
you have yet to mention your boy blue i
know i know
are you feeling i am i wasn't i i he's
right here i wasn't sure how to
come up with i was still thinking on the
fly as far as a superlative for that
game uh but go ahead you want to lead it
off there
well well here's what i'd like to do
yeah look at josh allen
the numbers were not quite what we
thought they would be the bills had two
weeks to get ready for the game they had
to
recover from the hail murray and they
couldn't get right back on the horse
they had to wait and justin herbert
you know he had another 300 yard passing
day he is doing exactly what joe burrow
was doing before he got injured which is
lighting up the league and herbert
likely will end up being the offensive
rookie of the year yeah let's do this
though because i spoke to alan
after the game about a variety of topics
let's put a p
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports